[موسيقى]
اذا مباراه المغرب وكرواتيا تنتهي
بالتعادل السلبي بين الفريقين شخصيه مش
مبسوط ولكن الجمهور المغربي
راح يقول لي ان شاء الله عمرك ما انبسطت
لان نحن مبسوطين واخذنا نقطه من كرواتيا
في مباراه صعبه جدا بكل امانه يعني اعتقد
ان المدربين كانوا راضيين بشكل كامل
بالتعادل او كانوا ربما
تكتيكيا متفقين على التعادل حتى التبديلات
رغم انها كانت تبدو تبديلات هجوميه
بالنسبه للمغرب بدخول عبد الصمد الزلزلي
وحمد الله وغيرهم من اللاعبين ولكن بكل
امانه يعني طريقه الاداء واسلوب اللعب لا
تقنعني ان هذا مستوى المنتخب المغربي
هجوميا لانه مستحيل اقتنع بصراحه يعني كان
الدفاع جيد نعم الوسط معقول الى حد ما
ولكن هجوميه للقرارات مش صحيحه كان في
اخطاء كثيره
بالقرار الهجومي بالتعامل بالثلث الامامي
واعتقد ان الموضوع كان باتفاق يعني ضمني
بين اللاعبين
والمدربين ان المباراه تطلع بالتعادل
وبعدين نفكر في مباراه كندا نفوز فيها
بعدين نحاول نخطف نقطه التعادل ونلجيكا
وبالتالي نتاهل على الدور الثاني بخمس
نقاط
هذا من وجهه نظري الصوره العامه او هي
الصوره العامه لهذه المباراه ولكن المغرب
وضع نفسه في خطر ااه كرواتيا وضعت نفسها
في خطر لانه الان اي فريق منهم راح يخسر
امام المنتخب البلجيكي لاحقا راح يفقد
امله او اماله بالتاهل بشكل ربما يكون
كامل ما بنعرف كيف راح تصيره الحسابات
لاحقا ولكن اي فريق منهم راح يخسر امام
بلجيكا راح تصير اموره صعبه جدا في هذه
المجموعه وراح تتعقد الامور كثير المنتخب
المغربي كان جيد جدا في عمليه التعامل مع
الهجمات الكرواتيه مع نقطه قوه المنتخب
الكرواتي واللي بيعتمد دائما على الكرات
الارضيه والترسيدات من خارج المنطقه كان
قادر يضبط المنتخب الكرواتي من هذه
الناحيه الجار كان رائع سايس كان رائع في
التعامل مع الكرات العاليه بالنسبه
للمنتخب الكرواتي مزراوي وحكيم علامات
استفهام كبيره على الاداء الهجومي يعني
نعم كان في مهارات من جانب حكيمي كان في
مستوى الدفاعي معقول جانب اللاعبين ولكن
هجوميا بالدقائق اللي يلعبها مصراوي قبل
ما يتبدل الاصابه وحكيمي حتى ما كان في
زيادات هجوميه الا باول 15 دقيقه اللي
دخلوا فيها المغرب وقلنا هنا المغرب شكلها
راح تخلص مباراه
بنتيجه كبيره جدا ربما تفوز بثلاثيه او
برباعيه لانه كان هيك الواضح في البدايه
ولكن حماس البدايات وتقسيمه المباراه
بتفهمك ان المغرب كان يسعى وراء التعادل
مش وراء الفوز في هذه المباراه لانه هذه
الراتب بعض ذلك وبعدين كرواتيا سيطرت على
الكره مع بدايه الشوط الثاني وفي النهايه
كان الامر انه ذهبت مباراه للتعادل
السلبيه بين الفريقين وصار عنها نقطه لكل
فريق خلينا نمشي بخطوط المغرب من حارس
المرمى ياسين بونو كان رائع انقذ اكثر من
كره وخصوص الكرات العرضيه اللي كانت تيجي
انقذها بشكل رائع جدا مثل ما حكينا الدفاع
المغرب كان منظم نعم كان قادر يتعامل مع
الكرات الارضيه كان قادر يواجه لاعبي
كرواتيا اقوياء بدنيه كان قادر يتعامل مع
الخطوره التسديدات كرواتي عن طريق
باريسيتش وعن طريق مودريتش رغم انه باريس
ستسدد تسديده بسبب خطا في التمرير من
املاح ولكن كانت هاي الفرصه الخطيره
لكرواتيا وما كان في غيرها تسديدات فينا
نقول انها خطيره من جانب المنتخب الكرواتي
على مرمى المنتخب المغربي وسط المنتخب
المغربي عليه علامات استفهام كبيره من
وجهه نظري سفيان همم مرابط يعني علامات
استفهام كبيره خساره كرات كانت كثير بنص
الملعب حتى املاح لم يكن مركز اليوم مناحي
كذلك يعني الثلاثي الثلاثي الوسط كان غير
قادر على وضع المهاجمين او الاجنحه في
اماكن تسمح لهم بتسجيل اهداف حتى دفاعيا
ما كانوا كثير ثابتين وقادرين يحموا
الدفاع ولكن كان ادائهم الى حد ما معقول
خلينا نقول نتوسط له جيد وله سيء هجوميا
نصيري علامات استفهام كبيره حول اداؤه
وعلامات استفهام اكبر حول الزج به اساسيا
في هذه المباراه نصيري ب 15 مباراه الموسم
الحالي مسجل هدفين بينما حمد الله بست
مباريات مسجل اربعه اهداف لذلك اعتقد انه
بظلم صوتي الى صوت جمهور المغرب اللي كان
بالملعب وعبى طالب بحمد الله يكون اساسي
او يتبدل بوقت اقرب من ذلك ولكن انتظر
وليد الاكرادي للدقيقه 78 لحتى نزل حمد
الله وهو في علامه استفهام كبيره وبرجع
بقول ربما انه كان عم يسعى وراء التعادل
وشاف انا الامور ماشي وبالتالي مش مضطر
انه عمل تغييرات كبيره داخل ارضيه الملعب
ومش مضطر انه يغامر لا يخطف الفوز باخر
دقائق من المنتخب الكرواتي حكيم زياش اول
ربع ساعه كان جيد كان قادر يعمل خطوره
ولكن بعد ذلك اختفى تماما ولكن انه صار
موجود بالملعب اي تاثير له وفاء لم يكن
بالمستوى المطلوب يعني علامات الاستفهام
كبيره
تبديل وكان ودخول الزلزولي ايضا الزلزوري
لم يقدم الاضافه اللازمه مع انه لاعب جيد
ولكن بعض صغير وتنقصه الكثير من الخبره
ليقدمها في كاس العالم لانه كاس العالم
يحتاج الى الخبره همم مبروك ربما المنتخب
المغربي اللي شايف جماهيره فرحانه
بالتعادل همم مبروك للجماهير المغربيه الى
لاعبي المنتخب المغربي ربما يمكن ان نقول
هارد لكن للمنتخب الكرواتي لانه تعادل
ربما كان بيسعى اكثر انه ما يحصل انه يكون
همم يقدر يحط الفوز باول المباراه ولكن
هذه كره القدم بالتوفيق للمنتخب المغربي
فما هو قادم وبتوفيق للجميع المنتخبات
المشاركه